on conféré aux activités de ces services
s'accompagneront d'un contrôle de chaque
opération de surveillance elles
s'accompagneront également d'un droit
pour les citoyens au recours
juridictionnel c'est une avancée dont il
faut prendre la juste mesure il est
inhabituel également que le Président de
la République annonce la saisine du
Conseil constitutionnel après les débats
et les vote du Parlement et bien sûr
avant la promulgation du texte sur les
points de droit les plus délicat cette
loi concerne le droit à la vie privée il
est donc naturel qu'elle SciTE des
interrogations et des inquiétudes et
légiférer sur des sujets aussi sensibles
c'est nécessairement s'entourer d'un
maximum de précautions dans ce même
hémicycle l'un de vos prédécesseurs
madame le garde des saau Henri Nalet
déclaré le 25 juin
1991 il présentait alors le projet de
loi sur le secret des correspondances
principale référence du texte qui nous
occupe aujourd'hui il déclarait donc en
prenant l'initiative de saisir le
Parlement de cette question le
gouvernement a bien conscience de
relever un véritable défi aujourd'hui
les circonstances sont un peu
différentes puisque ce texte s'appuie
sur un travail parlementaire approfondi
et
transpartisan le premier organe
parlementaire de contrôle a été créé en
2007 il s'agissait de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement chargée
de l'évaluation de la politique publique
et du contrôle de l'action du
gouvernement en matière de renseignement
je tiens d'ailleurs à rendre hommage au
travail de la délégation parlementaire
au enseignement j'ai eu l'occasion
d'ailleurs de m'exprimer devant elle à
plusieurs reprises comme ministre de
l'intérieur ou comme premier ministre
ainsi qu'à ceux d'entre vous qui en ont
présidé les travaux jean-jaces guest
jean-Pierre Sueur et désormais
Jean-Pierre rafarin cette institution a
su créer de véritables liens de
confiance avec le gouvernement comme
avec les services une communauté du
renseignement et des six services qui la
composent a été défin en 2007 également
le Conseil national du renseignement et
la fonction de coordinateur national du
renseignement ont été créé en 2008 et
l'Académie du renseignement en 2010 afin
que la communauté du renseignement se
professionnalise et se coordonne
davantage les missions de contrôle de la
DPR ont été élargies dans la loi de
programmation militaire de 2013 et la
loi de 1991 a été élargi aux données de
connexion d'ailleurs par un amendement
sénatorial monsieur le Président
particulièrement courageux les députés
hurvoisees de la majorité et verchè de
l'opposition ont cigner un rapport
parlementaire sur le sujet en
2013 notamment pour tirer les
enseignements des attentats de Toulouse
et de Montauban une inspection des
services de renseignement a été créée en
2014 elle vient d'ailleurs de se voir
confier ses deux premières missions
ainsi un travail de l'assemblée du Sénat
quel que soient les
majorités est à saluer le projet de loi
que vous allez examiner est donc
l'aboutiss d'une réflexion approfondie à
laquelle plusieurs d'entre vous ont
contribué de manière notable une
réflexion dont la droite comme la gauche
si c terme veut dire quelque chose dans
ce débat aujourd'hui ont vu l'utilité
elle est en ce sens profondément
républicaine c'est en juillet 2014 que
le Président de la République a décidé
de légiférer bien avant que notre pays
en janvier dernier ne soit frappé en
plein cœur mais il est vrai aussi face à
une menace que nous connaissons depuis
mars 2012 et face à l'intensité de cette
menace terroriste qui a frappé à
Copenhague à Tunis au Kenya nous avons
décidé d'accélérer ce travail et
d'envisager l'introduction de
dispositions spécifique à la lutte
antiterroriste sur de tels sujets
l'apport des Parlement est toujours
précieux pour l'exécutif je tiens
d'ailleurs à saluer le travail réalisé
par les membres de la commission
d'enquête sur l'organisation et les
moyens de la lutte contre les réseaux
jihadistes en France et en Europe
coprésidé par Nathalie Goulet et André
Richard et dont le rapporteur était
jean-Pierre Sueur certaines des
propositions présentées par cette
commission le 8 avril dernier figurent
d'ailleurs déjà dans ce texte de loi je
suis également certain que le rapport de
la commission d'enquête de l'Assemblée
nationale sur la surveillance des
filières et des individus jihadistes
présidés par Eric cioti et dont les
conclusions ont été présentées ce matin
à l'Assemblée nationale par Patrick
Menucci offrira de nouvelles pistes de
réflexion au gouvernement certaines
d'entre elles d'ailleurs sont déjà mises
en œuvre il est en effet
indispensable que notre dispositif de
lutte contre le terrorisme s'adapte en
permanence à une menace qui ne cesse
d'évoluer et de s'intensifier car il
faut en perman
s'adapter à cette menace qui est
particulièrement mouvante la France vous
le savez fait face à d'immenses défis
dans un monde marqué par
l'imprévisibilité la multiplication des
crises et la diversification des menaces
ces défis il faut les appréhender avec
lucidité et répondre afin que notre pays
puisse défendre son territoire ses
ressortissants et ses intérêts ses
valeurs aussi dans le respect de l'État
de droit le rôle des services de
renseignement est à ce titre fondamental
je tiens à rendre une nouvelle fois
devant vous hommage à ces combattant de
l'ombre qui mérite toute notre estime
leur action est par nature discrète mais
dans ces temps difficile elle est plus
que jamais nécessaire elle est même
primordiale
anticiper
détecter analyser et comprendre les
menaces qui pèsent sur la France c'est
garantir la sécurité du pays et comme le
soulignait déjà le général chinois sunsé
cher au Premier ministre Jean-Pierre
rafarin dans un ouvrage de stratégie une
armée sans agent secret est exactement
comme un homme sans yeux ni oreilles au
premier rang des missions de nos
services figure bien évidemment la
menace terroriste et tout
particulièrement la menace jjihadiste
c'est une menace globale où les
dimensions extérieur et intérieur se
confondent j'avais moi-même ici comme
ministre de l'Intérieur présentant la
loi antiterroriste en décembre 2012
évoquer cet ennemi intérieur et cet
ennemi
extérieur la radicalisation violente et
l'implication dans le terrorisme
islamiste ont explosé ces dernières
années dans tous les pays européens et
méditerranéens quelques chiffres pour
rappeler cette réalité des chiffres
d'ailleurs qui sans doute
n'éveillent pas suffisamment me
semble-t-il la conscience de beaucoup de
nos compatriotes mais ils sont
nécessaires pour comprendre la menace
plus de 1730 français ou personnes
résidants en France sont aujourd'hui
recensé pour leur application dans le
jihad en Syrie ou en Irak et ce chiffre
ne cesse d'augmenter il a plus que
doublé en un an c'est réalité
aujourd'hui euh euh Bernard casneuve la
connaît tous les jours dans ses
rencontres encore aujourd'hui même avec
ses homologues ministres de l'intérieur
des six principaux pays
européens plus de 860 individus ont
séjourné dans ces pays 471 y sont
actuellement et
110 sont recensés comme morts c'est 10
de plus qu'il y a de mois à peine
lorsque je pr présenter ce texte devant
l'Assemblée nationale et que je donnais
déjà ces chiffres la semaine dernière le
groupe terroriste daesh a revendiqué
deux attentats suicides menés en Irak
par deux de nos jeunes compatriotes cela
porte à neuf désormais le nombre
d'individus partis de France est décédés
dans des actions suicides même les
territoires ultramarins sont concernés
par ces phénomènes de radicalisation et
cela illustre aujourd'ui aujourd'hui les
redoutables capacités de nentriquement
de daesh la perversité de cette
organisation barbare qui attire les
étrangers dans ses rangs pour ensuite
les sacrifier le nombre d'individus à
suivre et à surveiller a explosé ce
phénomène nous le connaissons d'autres
pays le connaissent je rappelle que il
pourrait y avoir à la fin de
l'année près de 10000
européens en Syrie et en Irak 10000
pour les moyens humains le gouvernement
consent vous le savez des efforts sans
précédent plus de 1000 effectifs
supplémentaires pour la direction
générale de la sécurité intérieure d'ici
2017 2180 effectifs supplémentaires pour
les autres services de renseignement la
police judiciaire la justice et
l'administration pénitentiaire 30 % de
ces recrutements sont prévus en 2015 et
ils ont déjà débuté car il faut agir en
ce qui concerne les moyens juridiques ce
texte complète les deux lois de 2012
j'en ai dit un mot adopté fin 2012 près
un débat de très grande qualité première
lecture d'abord ici au Sénat qui
intégrait d'ailleurs un certain nombre
de propositions qui avaient été faites
et préparé par le gouvernement précédent
celui de François Fillon et par la loi
de
2014 adopté il y a quelques mois à peine
présenté par bernardu et qui renforce
l'arsenal antiterroriste nous devons
également prendre la mesure de la montée
en régime des cybermenaces qui n'ont
rien de virtuels ce sont des actes de
sabotage et les atteintes inacceptables
contre les libertés d'information et
d'expression la cuité de la menace
terroriste ne doit pas nous faire
oublier les autres risques auxquels
notre pays est
exposé ce sont ces risques qui portent
aussi les activités ce sont sur ces
risques que portent aussi pardon les
activités ité de nos services de
renseignement l'espionnage économique
qui emprend de plus en plus la voie des
cyberattaques coûte de nombreux emplois
à notre pays et la vigilance des
services de renseignement en matière de
prévention de ces prédations ne doit pas
être réservé à nos florons industriell
aux seules filières nucléairirees
aéronautique ou de défense elle concerne
aussi de nombreuses entreprises
innovantes de taille intermédiaire qui
voi trop souvent leur perspective de
développement ruiné par une captation de
leur savoir-faire notre stratégie de
redyamisation des filières industrielles
doit s'accompagner d'une lutte résolue
contre l'espionnage économique le
renseignement constitue également un
outil précieux d'aide à la décision en
matière de politique étrangère au sel en
centra-afrique en Irak notre armée
répond présent et pour promouvoir
l'action diplomatique par rapport à
l'action militaire nous employons notre
appareil de renseignement extérieur au
service de l'anticipation diplomatique
et nous devons en fin prévenir les
actions menées sur nos territoirees par
des groupes subversifs dont l'objectif
est de se livrer à des actes de violence
et de porter gravement atteinte à la
paix publique la rédaction de la loi de
1991 voulue par Michel Rocard laissait
sur ce point une grande part à
l'interprétation ainsi la surveillance
préventive du houliganisme violent
relève parfois de la rubrique Sécurité
Nationale parfois vois de la prévention
de la délinquence et de la criminalité
organisée le principe de l'égalité quel
vous êtes profondément attaché exige
davantage de clarté mais je veux le dire
devant vous de la manière la plus nette
l'ajout de cette nouvelle finalité ne
vise en rien à porter atteinte à la
liberté d'opinion ou de manifestation
les services de renseignement ne seront
pas autorisés à surveiller les actions
de défense d'une cause à partir du
moment où elles sont licites en outre
les opérations de surveillance ne seront
autorisées que si elles sont
proportionnées au risque encu le projet
de loi qui vous est soumis détaille
ainsi les finalités pour lesquelles les
services de renseignement pourront
demander le recours à certaines
techniques de surveillance intrusion
informatique sonorisation des lieux
privés ces finalités qui ont été
précisées par la commission des lois
correspondent finellement aux défis et
aux menaces que je viens d'évoquer et j'
e sur le fait que le gouvernement a opté
pour une définition de ces motifs légaux
beaucoup plus stricte je le dis par
rapport à certains
commentaires que la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme ne l'
autorise beaucoup plus
strict le projet de loi reprend
largement les dispositions existantes en
matière d'interception de sécurité et
d'accès aux données de connexion et il
les modernise car le précédent taxe
texte pardon datait d'avant l'arrivée du
téléphone portable et d'Internet il
procède également à des ajustements pour
prendre en compte les nouvelles
techniques de surveillance disponible
géolocalisation de véhicules ou d'objets
sonorisation captation d'images ou de
données informatiques dans des lieux
privés il tient pour cela compte du
cadre législatif créé en 2004 et
modernisé en 2011 en matière de
technique spéciale d'enquête dans le
domaine judiciaire ce texte fixe
également pour la première fois un cadre
juridique précis aux mesures de
surveillance internationale auxquels nos
services procèdent depuis le territoire
national et il s'agit d'une avancée
notable par rapport à la loi de 1991 qui
ne soumettait ses activités à aucun
contrôle ceux qui parfois s'émeuvent sur
les dispositions de ce texte ne se sont
pas beaucoup émus de cette absence de
règles depuis
1991 le texte prévoit enfin de nouveaux
dispositifs qui permettront un accès
encadré au réseau des opérateurs
téléphone et internet le suivi des
terroristes en temps réel sur le réseau
est nécessaire c'est indispensable et il
faut l'analyser comme un des éléments
majeurs aujourd'hui de la lutte contre
le terrorisme car les jihadistes
utilisent tous les outils du numérique
pour se livrer à des actions de
propagande et
d'embrigadement mais aussi pour échanger
le plus souvent en adoptant des
techniques sophistiquées afin d'éviter
d'être repéré c'est pour cette raison
que nous avons introduit une disposition
pour autoriser le recours aux
algorithmes ils permettront de détecter
les terroristes jusqu'àors inconnus
ainsi que les individus connus mais
recourant à des techniques de
dissimulation un autre chiffre pour
illustrer mon propos moins d'un
jihadiste sur de avait été détecté avant
son départ en Syrie si aucune loi bien
sûr ne pourra jamais garantir un taux de
détection et une efficacité préventive à
100 % nous devions néanmoins absolument
augmenter la capacité d'action de nos
services mais ce texte présente dans un
même mouvement et là aussi ne nous fions
pas aux
caricatures ce texte présente dans un
même mouvement donc de grandes avancées
en matière de protection des libertés
publiques il offre infiniment plus de
garantie que le dispositif légal
parcellaire actuel ce texte ne prévoit
donc pas je voudrais insister sur ce
point la mise en œuvre de moyens
d'exception j'avais d'ailleurs dit dans
mon intervention à l'Assemblée nationale
le 13 janvier que face à la menace
terrorisme il fallait évidemment une
réponse exceptionnelle mais pas des
mesures d'exception mais ne prévoit non
seulement pas la mise en uvre de
moyensex
et encore moins une surveillance
généralisée des citoyens le recueil de
renseignement sera ciblé sur les
personnes qui présentent une menace
réelle pour notre sécurité les principes
de finalité et de
proportionnalité l'extension des
compétences de la commission de contrôle
permettront de le garantir car toutes
les opérations de surveillance mené sur
le territoire national feront l'objet
d'un contrôle indépendant elles seront
à la connaissance de personnes parmi eux
deux ha magistrats administratifs deux
haut magistrats judiciaaires et qu
parlementaires dont deux de l'opposition
la commission verra ses moyens renforcés
pour accroître ce contrôle c'est la
garantie de son indépendance votre
rapporteur indique que votre assemblée y
est particulièrement attaché le
président de la CN CIS sollicitait d'ors
et déjà le renforcement de la Commission
à hauteur de 25 personnes le groupement
interministériel de contrôle service
placé sous l'autorité du Premier
ministre pas de manuel Vals du Premier
ministre verra lui aussi ses moyens
renforcés afin de pouvoir exercer ces
nouvelles missions une première
évaluation estime les moyens nécessaires
à 200 personnes contre 135 aujourd'hui
et 7 millions d'euros de budget annuel
supplémentaire au total pas moins de 250
personnes seront ainsi dédiées aux
fonctions de contrôle sans compter les
moyens de validation des décisions
internes à chaque service j'ai
d'ailleurs saisi l'inspection générale
des services de renseignement afin
qu'elle fasse des propositions concrètes
sur la mise en œuvre des garanties prévu
par cette loi la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement sera bien
sûr destinataire des conclusions de ces
travaux une extension modérée du nom de
personne à qui l'on peut déléguer
l'autorisation d'une procédure aussi
bien au cabinet des ministres que dans
celui du Premier ministre est nécessaire
c'est la conséquence logique de la
généralisation des procédures
d'autorisation et de l'impératif de
continuité opérationnelle 365 jours par
an en cas d'urgences et il y a les
urgences mais je veux répondre
expressément aux questions soulevées par
le président de la délégation
parlementaire au renseignement
Jean-Pierre affarin un lien de confiance
direct continuera de relier l'autorité
et le délégataire la responsabilité ne
peut pas être diluée donc elle ne sera
pas diluée et je salue l'amélioration
rédactionnel adopté monsieur le
rapporteur par la commission des lois
sur ce point comme sur bien d'autres et
le gouvernement et David de soumettre
les demandes de données de collection
les plus lourdes au visa du ministre ce
contrôle administratif qui s'ajoute au
dispositif existant DPR inspection des
services de renseignement et lui-même
complét par un contrôle juridictionnel
c'est une nouveauté et un progrès ce
contrôle sera confié au Conseil d'État
pour la première fois un juge pourra
ainsi enjoindre à l'exécutif de cesser
une opération de surveillance voir de
détruire les renseignement recueillis et
d'indemniser les victimes éventuelles et
on ne pourra pas lui opposer le secret
de la défense nationale la France soyons
fier disposera donc désormais d'un
dispositif de contrôle des services de
global cohérent et digne d'un État
démocratique avec son droit ses valeurs
et sans comparaison possible avec je ne
sais quelle décision prise outre
Atlantique le gouvernement a élaboré
avec laave du Conseil d'État un projet
de loi équilibré et qui se veut efficace
il s'agissait d'une part bien sûr de
contribuer au renforcement de la
sécurité des Français il nous le demande
tout en protégeant le leurs libertés
individuelles c'est une exigence il
s'agissait d'autre part de préserver la
distinction entre ce qui relève du
judiciaire et ce qui relève de
l'administratif sur certains sujets
notamment la prévention du terrorisme ou
la prévention de la criminalité de la
délinquence organisée vous le savez ce
qui suivent notamment ces questions la
frontière entre renseignement et
judiciaire n'est pas toujours simple à
tracer mais elle existe et nous devons
veiller à maintenir cette séparation
même si comme tout fonctionnaire les
personnels des services de renseignement
sont tenus d'aviser le procureur de la
République des crimes ou de délit dont
ils auraient connaissance dans
l'exercice de leur fonction c'est ce
même désir de veiller un double
équilibre entre sécurité et liberté
entre administratif et judiciaire qui a
guidé l'Assemblée nationale et la
commission des
lois et je veux de nouveau saluer son
travail et celui de son président pour
ce qui concerne le Sénat Philippe B
également rapporteur du texte grâce au
travail parlementaire le projet du
gouvernement a été amendé précisé sur
plusieurs points afin de dissiper les
ambigués et d'apporter de nouvelles
garanties lorsque cela est apparu
nécessaire ainsi lors de l'examen du
texte en commission la possibilité de
recourir à la procédure de l'urgence
absolu a été restreinte à deux finalités
l'autorisation de recueil en temps réel
des données de connexion des terroristes
a été réduite à 2 mois et les modalités
de recours au dispositifs techniques de
proximité de type MC catcher ont été
reprécisés s'agissant des surveillances
en milieu pénitentiaire notamment en
matière de prévention du terrorisme ou
des activités de criminalité organisée
le Sénat a souhaité examiner la question
en détail comme l'avait fait à
l'Assemblée comme l'avait fait
l'Assemblée nationale la commission des
lois préconise d'aller au-delà du droit
positif actuel qui permet aux chefs
d'établissement pénitentiaires de
procéder à des surveillances pour la
préservation du bon ordre au sein de
l'établissement et la prévention des
évasions le gouvernement la garde des
saau s'exprimera au cours du débat
considère comme une voix
particulièrement intéressante de prévoir
par une base législative les modalités
de coopération entre l'administration
pénitencière et les services de
renseignement mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs je suis certain que les
échanges constructifs que vous allez
avoir dans les prochains jours avec les
ministres de la Justice de la Défense et
de l'Intérieur permettront d'enrichir
encore ce texte et d'apporter des
améliorations substantielles le
gouvernement participera bien sûr à ce
débat en déposant ou en soutenant des
amendements ainsi pour donner au
services la latitude dont ils ont besoin
le gouvernement souhaite que le délai de
conservation des données de connexion
s'établissent à 4 ans ils étaient de 5
ans dans le projet adopté par
l'Assemblée mais mais il a été réduit à
3 ans par la commission des lois de
récentes affaires ont pourtant prouvé
l'utilité d'une telle disposition pour
retracer le parcours des terroristes il
est important également que le délai de
conservation des correspondances
recueilli par le bien d'interception de
sécurité soit maintenu à 30 jours comme
l'a voté la commission ces 30 jours sont
nécessaires car il est souvent utile de
réécouter plusieurs fois les
enregistrements pour décoder des propos
énigmatiques après recoupement de
certaines informations un amendement
vous sera ensuite proposé afin de
préciser les modalités de centralisation
des données recueillies au moyen d'un
dispositif technique de proximité de
type imsat cher s'il est en effet
indispensable que le GIC ou la cncttr
dispose des éléments recueillis afin
d'en faire un contrôle exhaustif les
services doivent quant à eux pouvoir
continuer à les exploiter de manière
opérationnelle une centralisation
directe et exclusif des informations
recueilllies par le GIC n'est donc pas
souhaitable en revanche une copie de
contrôle sera systématiquement adressé
au j par les services et sera ainsi à la
disposition permanente de la CN
CTR je connais les débats qui entourent
certaines dispositions et le
gouvernement vous soumettra également
des amendements visant apporter des
garanties supplémentaires à titre
d'exemple s'agissant des opérations
nécessitant une intrusion domiciliaire
il vous sera proposé de prévoir une
saisine automatique du Conseil d'État
dès lors qu'un avis défavorable de la
CTR n'aurait pas été suivi la plus haute
juridiction administrative française
faut-il encore le rappeler aurait alors
24 heures pour se prononcer sur la
validité de l'autorisation accordée par
le Premier ministre ou par un de ses
délégués par ailleurs s'agissant des
algorithmes visant à détecter des
signaux faibles sur les réseaux des
opérateurs de téléphonie et internet il
vous sera proposé d'apporter de
nouvelles garantie à savoir la
destruction rapide de toutes les données
concernant des personnes sur lesquelles
les recherches complémentaire effectué
n'aurait pas confirmé le lien avec le
terrorisme enfin un amendement du
Gouvernement visera à préciser l'article
relatif aux mesures de surveillance
internationale les procédures
d'encadrement du recueil et de
l'exploitation des données seront
notablement notablement explicité il en
va de même pour les modalités
spécifiques de contrôle par la
commission et le recours juridictionnel
ainsi soyons précis là aussi dès qu'un
numéro d'abonnement ou un identifiant
sera rattachable au territoire français
les correspondances seront exploitées
selon les mêmes règles que si elles
avaient été émises sur le territoire
national je profite merci monsieur le
président de cette occasion pour
rappeler que la DGSE comme la plupart
des grands services de renseignement
extérieur dispose de capacité
d'interception portant exclusivement sur
les communications internationales et
que leur exploitation s'exerce dans les
limites des finalités prévues
aujourd'hui par la loi de 1991 et demain
par ce texte c'est conforme aux missions
de ce service et c'est indispensable
pour la sécurité et la souveraineté de
notre pays et contrairement à ce qui
peut être dit ou écrit la DGSE n'exerce
pas non plus de surveillance massive des
Français et n'a pas accès au centre de
stockage des opérateurs elle ne procède
à aucune interception des communications
échangées sur le territoire français en
dehors des interceptions de sécurité
légale ce projet loi constituera j'en
suis certain un progrès important pour
les services de renseignement il le
demande d'ailleurs pour leur propre
protection comme pour notre démocratie
mais il ne constitue pas un
aboutissement les mécanismes et
procédures prévu par ce texte devront
vivre avec la même force et le même
caractère protecteur que la loi de 1991
celle-ci a joué son rôle de gardefou
avec efficacité j'ai bien noté que les
AM amendements ont été déposés par les
sénateurs afin d'engager une réflexion
sur le contrôle des fichiers des
services de renseignement la président
de l'acnil le demande par ailleurs avec
insistance l'acnil peut déjà exercer le
contrôle individuel de ses fichiers à la
demande de tout particulier à travers
l'exercice du droit personnel d'accès
mais mais et je veux insister sur ce
point nous devons nous garder de
bouleverser les équilibres des lois de
1978 et de 1991 et veiller à ne pas
installer de mécanisme de contrôle d'un
même objet par deux autorités
administratives différentes et
susceptibles de devenir concurrente nous
devons également garantir la protection
des sources humaines et le bon
fonctionnement de la coopération
internationale en revanche il est
possible de développer une politique de
contrôle interne plus dynamique des
fichiers de renseignement en lien avec
la délégation parlementaire et je
confierai au second semestre une mission
à l'inspection générale des services de
renseignement pour étudier cette
question nous devons également abord
aborder le sujet de la coopération entre
les services des progrès ont été faits
je le disais au cours des dernières
années notamment à l'initiative du
coordinateur national du renseignement
des mutualisations ont été engagées en
particulier dans le domaine technique
sur le plan opérationnel souvent à
l'initiative des ministres de la Défense
et de l'intérieur les relations entre
services se sont améliorées et nous ne
pouvons que nous en féliciter c'est
indispensable pour lutter contre le
terrorisme je salue ainsi la création en
cours au sein des locaux de la DGSI
d'une Tasque force exclusivement dédiée
à la problématique des filières
djihadistes
siro-irakiennes composé de membres des
six services de la communauté de
renseignement elle devrait prochainement
associer des représentants du service de
renseignement territorial et de larpp en
anticipation peut-être d'une ouverture
de la communauté du renseignement à ces
deux nouvelles administrations les
progrès sont sans doute encore possibles
ils sont en tout cas indispensables afin
d'éviter des doublons des pertes
d'information dont on imagine à quel
point elles seraiit préjudici
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ce
texte mérite et je sais que ça sera le
cas ici une discussion à la hauteur de
son importance je souhaite qu'il
recueille bien sûr un large soutien car
je considère que sur des sujets aussi
importants pour la sécurité et la
liberté de nos concitoyens les
principales forces politiques doivent
être capable de concertation et d'esprit
de responsabilité c'est en tout cas
l'exigence de nos compatriotes
et pour conclure je reprendrai les mots
prononcés le 13 juin 1991 par edit
cresson Premier ministre qui défendait
alors la loi relative aux interceptions
de sécurité elle disait de plus en plus
de responsables politiques souhaitaent
faire la lumière il ne manquait que la
volonté voir le courage politique c'est
pourquoi nous avons choisi de débattre
sur cette question de la façon la plus
démocratique et la plus incontestable
qui soit c'est-à-dire par la loi
aujourd'hui disait-elle
le gouvernement vous invite à franchir
le pas 24 ans plus tard nous relevons le
défi et nous vous invitons et c'est un
honneur pour moi de nouveau à franchir
le pas je vous
remercie merci Monsieur le Premier
Ministre la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur le président Philippe
B rapporteur de la commission des
lois vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président le
rapport monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Ministre madame la garde des
saauieur ministre chers collègues en
abordant ce débat j'ai à l'esprit une
longue histoire qui a fait du Sénat l'un
des fondateurs de la République moderne
et le plus farouche défenseur des
libertés publiques tout que nous
siégions nous faisons notre l'héritage
de Victor Hugo comme ce de Victor
schulcher d'Auguste churur Kessner et
aujourd'hui celui de Robert d'Inter sans
pour autant récuser George clémenau ou
Michel Debray le Sénat c'est la
République la République dans toutes ses
dimensions c'est la liberté et c'est
l'autorité la régulation des activités
de
renseignement soulève de nombreuses
questions qui mettent en jeu nos droits
fondamentaux puiss la grande tradition
du Sénat lib
républicains nous inspirer les bonnes
réponses ce débat va nous conduire au
cœur de notre contrat social les
questions auxquelles nous devrons
répondre sont bien sûr des sens
politiques dans leur principe elles ne
sont certes pas nouvelles mais elles se
posent aujourd'hui à propos de nouveaux
moyens d'intrusion dans la vie
privée ces moyens sont fondés sur des
technique de surveillance en pleine
évolution ils ont déjà gravement défrayé
l'actualité mi dans un contexte
d'insécurité dont le premier ministre à
juste titre n'a pas manqué de rappeler à
l'instant la gravité et
l'actualité comment renforcer la
sécurité sans mettre en péril la
liberté comment assurer l'efficacité
d'une action de renseignement qui
postule le secret tout en la soumettant
à des limites qui impose de porter sur
elle un regard
extérieur face à ces questions la
République n'est pas dénué d'expérience
elle a depuis longtemps inventé une
méthode cette méthode consiste à
approfondir l'État de droit en nous
appuyant sur nos institutions et nos
procédures légales et en refusant
l'arbitraire de texte d'exception où la
fin justifierait les moyens où l'urgence
s'imposerait au droit aux nécessités
ferait loi l'exigence de Sénat celle
dont je suis comme vous tous porteur
c'est d'inscrire cette loi dans le droit
commun c'est ainsi que nous resterons
fidèles aux équilibres posés par la
déclaration de
1789 qui a su proclamer les droits
naturels et imprescriptibles de l'homme
tout en fixant immédiatement des bornes
à ses droits pour je la cite dans sa
belle langue défendre les actions
nuisibles à la
société ce projet confronte les intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation ainsi que la
sauvegarde de vie humaine à des
exigences aussi fortes que le respect de
la vie privée et la garantie des
libertés fondamentales il n'y a certes
pas d'impératif plus élevé que la
sauvegarde de la vie humaine mais le
combat pour la sécurité ne peut
justifier que des atteintes aux droits
et libertés strictement et évidemment
nécessaire le projet de loi a pour but
de donner un cadre légal au service de
renseignement pour prévenir des crimes
et défendre nos intérêts nationaux ce
faisant il ne donne aux acteurs du
renseignement aucun moyen supplémentaire
ce n'est pas son
objet ce texte a été accusé tour à tour
d'autoriser une surveillance de masse au
profit de l'État d'imiter le patriote
acte de George bouche de tenir le juge à
distance de légitimer par avance
l'arbitraire policier pour excessif
qu'il soit parfois les quisitoir que
nous entendons sont salutaires en
démocratie ils constitueent autant
d'anticorps venant de la société pour
que notre État de droit résiste à
l'inoculation de réflexes toxiqu pour
nos libertés
fondamentales nous voyons bien les
insuffisances de ce texte nous voulons
les corriger mais sa conception et son
architecture repose sur des fondements
solides qui ne contreviennent en rien à
la tradition républicaine jamais nous ne
pourrions soutenir un projet qui
ressemblerait à la caricature que
certains en ont faite pour répondre aux
inquiétudes nous devons faire ensemble
de ce texte une grande loi républicaine
il va nous falloir déterminer avec
rigueur l'étendue des pouvoirs conférés
au service de renseignement il nous
reviendra de prendre position sur les
bornes que l'autorité publique peut
légitimement assigner à la liberté et au
respect de la vie privée ce ne sera pas
la première fois
ce n'est pas chose facile c'est un choix
de responsabilité et de mesure il nous
confronte à la nécessité d'accepter des
concessions pour la défense des intérêts
collectifs sans renoncer à l'absolu que
la liberté représente pour nous face à
une question aussi cruciale toute
pression instrumentalisant le terrorisme
serait évidemment déplacé la lutte
contre le terrorisme ne permet pas tout
et nexcuse pas tout ce texte très
important n'est d'ailleurs pas une
réaction au CRIM terroriste commis en
janvier dernier il est issu du travail
de la délégation parlementaire au
renseignement il tient compte aussi des
réflexions de notre commission d'enquête
sur le djihadisme la République n'aurait
que faire d'instaurer une surveillance
de masse la mission des services de
renseignement va être mieux définie
votre commission y a veillé il s'agit de
prévenir des crimes et des délits
d'empêcher des aner des attentats de
faire échec à des menaces sur nos
intérêts nationaux les plus fondamentaux
économiques et scientifiques et de
promouvoir ses intérêts par l'action
extérieure rien de plus et c'est déjà
beaucoup repérer ce qui nous menace
n'implique qu'une surveillance ciblée
exactement le contraire d'une
surveillance de masse laquelle ne serait
que perte de temps et gaspillage de
ressources par rapport aux objectifs
poursuivis tout ce qui pourrait s'en
rapprocher doit naturellement être évité
et c'est le rôle du Sénat d'y
veiller avec ce projet de loi il s'agit
d'introduire des garanties pour nos
concitoyens là où il n en a pas de
passer du non droit au
droit certainement pas de créer une
surveillance sans limite ni contrôle au
contraire le souci de prévenir ce risque
justifie l'intervention du législateur
la loi restreindra possibilité de
surveillance de l'état en instituant des
règles et des contrôles qui n'existaient
pas l'encadrement des techniques de
renseignement apparaît nécessaire à
plusieurs stades lors de l'autorisation
des actions de renseignement en fonction
de finalités et de critères précis au
moment de la mise en œuvre des
techniques et enfin par l'intervention
d'un juge chargé de faire respecter nos
droits
fondamentaux je vous propose une ligne
directrice simple plus les techniques de
renseignement utilisées seront
intrusives plus les garanties devront
être importantes les écoutes
téléphoniques sont déjà réglementé par
la loi de
1991 qui les soumet à une autorisation
du Premier ministre ou de son
représentant sur avis de la Commission
nationale de contrôle des interceptions
de sécurité la réforme s'inspire de ce
dispositif en l'étendant et en
l'adaptant à tous les services de
renseignement et à toutes les techniques
de renseignement votre commission des
Lois a recentré la notion d'entourage en
matière
d'écoute limiter dans le temps le
recours aux IMS catcher restreint les
données susceptibles d'être collectées
par ces dispositif au seul numéro de
boîtier de téléphone et de carte SIM en
excluant les fadettes elle a aussi
précisé que le recueil de données en
temps réel pour les personnes présentant
une menace terroriste serait soumis à un
examen au cas par cas la procédure
d'urgence étant alors exclue par
ailleurs elle a étroitement circonscrit
la définition de la technique de
l'algorithme et resserré les conditions
du recours à cette technique elle a
aussi prévu une durée d'application plus
limitée dans le temps 2 mois le
renouvellement du dispositif étant
assorti de conditions afin d'encadrer
davantage le recours à ces traitements
automatisés qui focalisent les
inquiétudes et pour les techniques les
plus intrusives comme l'accès au disque
dur d'un ordinateur la sonorisation ou
la captation d'images votre commission a
également renforcé les garanties prévues
par le
texte une fois autorisé
les techniques de renseignement doivent
être mieux
contrôlées votre commission des Lois a
voulu imposer la pleine application du
principe de légalité aux techniques de
renseignement pour sortir du non drroit
le système que nous proposons a pour but
de prévenir les surveillances illégales
et si une transgression était constatée
d'obtenir une anulation rapide par
exemple dans le cas où la procédure n'a
pas respecté la loi ou si la finalité de
la surveillance n'est pas légale si la
motivation est insuffisante si les
mesures ne sont pas strictement
proportionnées au fin poursuivi ou
encore si la conservation des données
excède la durée de
l'autorisation nous avons défini avec
précision le cahier des charges de la
légalité en matière de renseignement la
commission l'a inscrit au premier
article du texte il s'imposera au
service
dans leur action à la Commission
nationale de contrôle dans l'évaluation
des demandes d'autorisation et dans
l'accomplissement de sa mission de
contrôle au Premier ministre dans sa
décision et bien sûr au Conseil d'État
dans l'appréciation qu'il fera de la
légalité des autorisations et de la
régularité des actes des services de
renseignement il
faut que le contrôle soit
effectif et pour qu'il le soit une
autorité indépendante doit être
instituer afin de vérifier que les
conditions légales sont réunies
préalablement à toute utilisation des
techniques de renseignement il faut que
cette autorité soit dotée de pouvoir
d'investigation étendu si l'urgence doit
être prise en compte elle doit être
tellement exceptionnelle et tellement
contrôlée qu'elle ne puisse vider la
procédure de droit commun de sa
substance l'indépendance de la
commission vis-à-vis du gouvernement
doit être assuré par sa composition ses
moyens d'action ses prérogatives et son
accès aux données recueillies sur tous
ces points votre commission des Lois a
souhaité et inscrit des garanties
supplémentaires composé de
membres la Commission s'inscrira dans la
séparation des pouvoirs puisqu'elle sera
constituée de représentant du pouvoir
législatif et du pouvoir juridictionnel
sans aucune représentation du pouvoir
exécutif de plus Jean-Pierre rafarin et
moi-même avons déposer une proposition
de loi organique soumettant la
désignation du président de la CNCT à un
vote des commission compétente des deux
assemblées en application de l'article
13 de la constitution et cela pour
conforter son
indépendance une fois l'avis de la
commission nationale rendue le Premier
ministre doit prendre sa décision comme
aujourd'hui on peut penser qu'il suivra
généralement l'avis de la commission et
cela d'autant plus que le contrôle du
Conseil d'État sera devenu effectif il
n'y a pas mieux que l'anticipation de la
sanction pour garantir le respect du
droit cont tenu du nombre de demandes à
traiter il est normal que le premier
ministre puisse déléguer sa décision à
des collaborateurs directs comme c'est
déjà le cas en matière d'écoute
téléphonique mais prenons garde à ne pas
laisser se constituer à Matignon dans
les ministères concernés et dans les
services de la Commission Nationale un
véritable corps de professionnels
spécialisés dans le droit du
renseignement agissant en initié la
décision d'autorisation ne sa pourrait
être bureaucratique vous l'avez rappelé
d'ailleurs Monsieur le Premier Ministre
elle engage la responsabilité de
l'autorité publique sous le contrôle
ultime du
Parlement pour inscrire pleinement la
régulation des activités de
renseignement dans un cadre légal la
question du juge et de ses pouvoirs et
sans doute la question essentielle
elle n'a peut-être pas été suffisamment
discutée jusqu'à maintenant il n'y a pas
d'État de droit sans l'intervention d'un
juge au juge de l'autorité publique
revient la mission de soumettre l'action
publique au respect de la légalité et de
suspendre ou d'annuler ses excès de
pouvoir au juge
pénal revient de sanctionner les crimes
et délits y compris s'ils ont été commis
par un agent de l'autorité publique dans
l'exercice de sa fonction en pénétrant
irrégulièrement dans un domicile ile ou
en interceptant illégalement des
correspondances ce modèle présente de
nombreuses avantage et je le défends
sans complexe il a le mérite d'être le
plus complet il couvre la prévention
autant que la répression et la
réparation la police
administrative à laquelle se rattache
l'activité du renseignement c'est
l'action préventive de l'État contre le
crime et la délinquence pour l'empêcher
dans
le cas de la police préventive des vies
sont parfois en jeu il faut agir vite
sur le fondement d'éléments parfois
minces on mesure avec la lutte contre le
terrorisme à quel point cette mission
régalienne et vitale car elle vis en
dernier sort à empêcher des crimes aussi
abominables que ce commis en janvier
mais elle doit être soumise au principe
de l'égalité sous le contrôle de son
juge pour que la fin aussi noble
soit-elle ne justifie que l'engagement
de moyens légaux et
proportionnés votre commission des Lois
a tenu à renforcer cette exigence en
rendant le contrôle du Conseil d'État
effectif il ne l'était pas et cela sans
pour autant entraver l'action publique
quand elle respecte la loi il faut que
le juge puisse facilement être saisi en
cas d'abus si l'on veut vraiment donner
au Conseil d'État un rôle régulateur il
faut qu'il soit est amené à se prononcer
assez souvent c'est pourquoi votre
commission des Lois a prévu qu'il
suffirait de trois membres de la
commission nationale pour contester une
mesure de surveillance devant la Haute
juridiction le Conseil d'État verra
ainsi ses pouvoirs renforcés il pourra
suspendre les mesures contestées les
annuler ordonner la destruction des
renseignements recueillis indemniser les
victimes d'une surveillance irrégulière
la trame de ces décisions revêtues de
l'autorité de la chose jugée permettra
d'établir progressivement un guide
précis de la légalité des autorisations
données aux services spéciaux auxquels
le Premier ministre devra se
soumettre chacun doit être bien
convaincu à commencé par les agents des
services spécialisés eux-mêmes que le
Conseil d'État à partir d'un accès
illimité aux pièces du dossier pourra
intervenir vite et fort en annulant les
actes qu'il aura jugé illégaux et en
ordonnant la destruction de tous les
documents et information irrégulièrement
réunis la loi devra aussi reconnaître la
place essentielle du juge pénal que la
Commission nationale et le Conseil
d'État devront pouvoir
saisir en donnant sous de strictes
conditions un cadre légal à des
pratiques de renseignement aussi
intrusive et exceptionnel que la posuse
de micro dans des domiciles ou des
bureaux l'installation de balises dans
des véhicules ou la captation à distance
des données du disque dur d'un
ordinateur la loi rejettera dans la
catégorie des délits les mêmes
agissements mis en œuvre en dehors de ce
cadre elle ouvrira ainsi un nouveau
champ d'action au juge pénal pour
condamner et punir toute dérives illégal
d'agent des services spécialisés tout ce
qui n'entre pas dans le cadre légal
pourra désormais relever du délit
d'atteinte au respect de la vie privée
ou de violation du
domicile la Commission a souhaité que la
loi le dise
expressément nous avons aussi voulu
assoir l'autorité de la commission
nationale en instaurant un délit
d'entrave sanctionné par le juge pénal
si un service de l'État refuse de
répondre à ces demandes enfin si l'objet
d'une demande de surveillance par une
technique de renseignement relève en
réalité de la police judiciaire la
demande devra être réorientée vers le
procureur pour déclencher une enquête
judiciaire le
Sénat aura à tranché de nombreuses
autres questions la protection des
journalistes et des avocats et des
parlementaires le rôle du renseignement
pénitentiaire les délais de conservation
des renseignements recueillis par les
services
l'étendue lapportter du nouveau fichier
antiterroriste le cantonnement des
procédures d'urgence à des situations
réellement exceptionnel la mission
spécifique des parlementaires dans la
Commission nationale de contrôle des
technique de renseignement la place des
lanceurs d'alerte dans tous les cas nous
aurons à le faire en défenseur des
libertés mais aussi avec le souci de
l'efficacité
de l'action publique conscient de
l'importance des enjeux d'intérêt
national que nous avons à relever fidèle
à sa tradition le Sénat entend ainsi
être une fois de plus au rendez-vous de
l'État de
droit
merci monsieur le rapporteur de la
commission des lois merci monsieur le
Président la parole va maintenant au
président Jean-Pierre rfarin rapporteur
pour avis de la commission des affaires
étrangères de la défense et des forces
armé vous avez la parole monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Premier Ministre mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues
liberté et
sécurité la dialectique n'est pas au
fond nouvelle mais placer les activités
des services de renseignement dans un
cadre défini par le législateur
constitue une marque de maturité pour
une démocratie et un progrès
considérable de l'État de droit la
démarche monsieur le Premier ministre
est ambitieuse le législateur doit agir
en responsabilité son action est
nécessaire et me semble-t-il il est
parvenu au terme du travail en
commission à un équilibre
raisonnable la démarche entreprise est
ambitieuse il faut le souligner nous
saluons Monsieur le Premier Ministre
cette ambition d'autant qu'elle n'est
pas toujours présente dans tous les
textes qui nous sont ici
présentes cependant nous le notons pour
ce texte car longtemps on a considéré
que un tel texte risquait d'affaiblir
les capacités des services or ce risque
selon moi n'est pas avéré si l'on
procède avec précaution dans une société
démocratique marqué par la liberté de
communication et le renforcement du
droit c'est l'absence de cadre légal qui
constitue un risque légiférer assoir la
légitimité des services mieux faire
comprendre leur mission ce n'est donc
pas de mon point de vue les affaiblir
mais au contraire les renforcer M chers
collègues pensez une seconde à l'état de
notre République à laquelle nous sommes
attachés si un criminel terroriste après
avoir multiplié des
méfas étant sorti de ses aventures de
manière positive quant à sa santé
faisait un procès aux instances de la
République et arrivit à gagner au procès
parce que les services auraient employé
des techniques illégales quel ridicule
la République devrait affronter je pense
que nous devons légiférer en la matière
pour protéger l'action de nos services
légiférer n'est évidemment pas chose
facile car le législateur doit agir en
faisant preuve d'une double
responsabilité responsabilité à l'égard
évidemment de nos concitoyens qui
doivent bénéficier d'une politique
efficace du renseignement de nature à
les protéger contre des risques graves
de déstabilisation ou d'attentat sans
que soit mis en place un système
abusivement intrusif responsabilité
aussi à l'égard des services de
renseignement des fonctionnaires et
militaires qui les servent qui
effectuent un travail disusons-le ici à
cette tribune remarquable la plupart du
temps dangereux dans des conditions
toujours difficiles et dont les succès
sont par construction vouz à rester dans
l'ombre quand il y a un certain nombre
de difficultés et sans jamais être mise
en valeur quand il y a réussite ces
agents aspirent à a œuvrer pour la
France dans un cadre juridique stable
solide légitime mais qui garantissent
aussi l'efficacité et la confidentialité
des opérations qu'ils conduisent tous
seront donc questions dans ce texte et
dans nos débats dans les procédures qui
vont être mises en œuvre de la recherche
de l'équilibre ce texte était attendu
évidemment de longue date il n'est en
réalité exceptionnel parce qu'il est le
premier du genre dans notre pays et qui
met fin à une exception parmi les
démocraties avancées ce texte est
également nécessaire pour répondre à
l'évolution des menaces évidemment et
servir principalement et c'est là
l'essentiel les intérêts du pays telle
est l'opinion de votre commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées ce texte réaffirme la
notion de politique publique du
renseignement et la précise en
s'appuyant sur deux notions très
importantes définies par le législateur
la stratégie de sécurité nationale d'une
part et d'autre part la défense et la
promotion des intérêts fondamentaux du
pays ça je crois c'est très important
stratégie de sécurité nationale et
d'autre part défense et promotion des
intérêts fondamentaux de la nation ce
texte pose également la qualité première
de l'État en la matière compétence
exclus de l'État en ce domaine le sujet
dont nous parlons est un sujet de
compétence exclusive de l'État il
consolide donc l'importance de
l'organisation de la réorganisation
devrais-je dire qui a été engagé dans
l'organisation de nos services ce projet
de loi mérite de rappeler que les
missions et les finalités pour
lesquelles ils peuvent recourir les
services à des techniques spécifiques
sauf exception ne se limite pas à la
seule prévention du terrorisme c'est je
crois un point important que nous aurons
à débattre en ce qui concerne les
finalités le spectre des menaces est en
effet beaucoup plus large et inclut
notamment la lutte contre toute forme
d'ingérance
étrangère contre l'espionnage industriel
et scientifique dont on ne parle pas
suffisamment et contre la criminalité et
la délinquence organisée on est très
focalisé sur le terrorisme mais pensons
à l'élargissement des finalités en outre
l'action des services sétend à la
collecte d'informations destinée à
permettre aux autorités de notre pays
d'effectuer en toute autonomie les choix
nécessaires à la conduite de la
politique étrangère et vraiment ce qui
est fondamental aussi monsieur le
ministre à la politique de défense du
pays jeis dire que il est rare qu'au
fond dans notre pays on puisse renforcer
la République en ant l'exécutif et de ce
point de vue-là surtout ce qui'est le
régalien il est important que nous
soyons rassemblés pour qu'il puisse
disposer leur égalien des outils
nécessaires à l'exercice de son autorité
l'extension évidemment à des nouvelles
techniques et nécessaires pour
l'ensemble de nos pratiques les menaces
sont amplifiées et leur mode d'action
devient maintenant chacun le constate
bien extrêmement sophistiqué et celui
qui se dote pas de moyens d'action
performant se place en situation de
faiblesse il est donc très important de
préserver les capacité des services en
les autorisant à recourir à des
techniques modernes de recueil de
renseignement il y a là une course dans
lequel l'autorité ne peut pas accepter
une position de recul ou de retrait
encore faut-il que l'usage de ces
techniques s'inscrive évidemment dans un
cadre légal
qui le limite et qui garantisseent la
protection contre les atteintes abusives
à la vie privée et aux libertés c'est
évidemment une mission historique du
Sénat Philippe Bas président de notre
commission des lois et rapporteur l'a
démontré tout à l'heure avec talent
précision et rigueur il ne s'agit pour
nous donc non pas d'une loi d'exception
elle n'a d'exceptionnel que d'intervenir
dans un domaine non encore saisi par le
droit le texte qui vous est soumis a
donc de mon point de vue réussi à
parvenir à un équilibre de satisfaisant
raisonnable et globalement responsable
nous avons pour ce faire déposé un
certain nombre d'amendements au sein de
la commission des affaires étrangères de
la défense et des forces armées et nous
avons apprécié que la Grande commission
des lois de notre République ici au
Sénat et bien voulu accepter les
amendements de la commission de la
politique des Affaires étrangères et au
total et j'en remercie le président
rapporteur et tous les membres monsieur
sur de la Commission de l'opposition
comme de la majorité qui font qu'on a eu
sur ce sujet une coopération
constructive et fertile et c'est je
crois une des conditions euh de
mobilisation pour ce quand je rejoins le
Premier ministre sur ce sujet il est
clair que sur des questions de cette
nature l'autorité d'un texte dépend
aussi de la qualité de la majorité qui
le vote je me souviens en mon sentend
d'un texte sur le voile à l'école qui a
fait autorité qui a pu avoir cette
autorité parce que autour du
gouvernement de l'époque il y avait eu
un
rassemblement qui permet de donner à un
texte une large autorité je veux dire
que sur ce point on a vu avec la
commission des lois un certain nombre de
progrès très important enregistré on a
pris en compte la notion d'intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation ça je crois
que c'est essentiel les intérêts
fondamentaux de la nation dans la
définition des missions et des finalités
on a redimensionné la
CNCT on a entendu un peu les dans les
différentes auditions la vie des gens
engagés des responsables des différentes
autorités plus une autorité est
nombreuse moins elle est efficace en
général une CNCT de de Neu membres
serait meilleur de notre point de vue
qu'à une CNCT de 13 memb on a conforté
la légitimité de son président et son
indépendance par la loi organique que
nous avons proposé avec Philippe Bas qui
donnera donc à au Sénat la possibilité
de participer à la légitimité de la
désignation du président on a revu la
durée de conservation des correspondance
intercepté pour qu'elle soit raisonnable
on a limité un angle mort dans la
capacité d'agir des services par par
l'interdiction absolue de procéder à la
mise en place de certains dispositifs
lorsque des personnes visées
appartiennent à des professions
protégées ce qui fournit quelquefois des
couvertures faciles pour des agents
étrangers des terroristes ou des
criminels on a recadré de notre point de
vue ce dispositif ça nous paraît être un
progrès on a rendu aussi plus
intelligibles les dispositions relatives
à certaines techniques et on a
actualiser la rédaction des dispositions
relatives à la délégation parlementaire
au renseignement cette délégation nous
paraît être un lieu responsable lié par
le secret défense pour pouvoir débattre
avec l'exécutif des questions les plus
sensibles sur ces sujets le travail en
séance publique consistera à parfaire
donc un certain nombre de points qui
sont encore en discussion je vous
présenterai certains amendements sur
lesquels il me semble utile que le Sénat
entier puisse prononcer l'exercice de sa
responsabilité première préoccupation
les intérêts de la politique étrangère
dans la qualification du texte par
l'épithèque essentiel ça me paraît
dangereux tel que c'est actuellement
défini car monsieur le Premier ministre
dans ce domaine seul l'exécutif doit
assurer une réelle prééminence pour
définir ce qui est essentiel dans la
politique étrangère du pays seconde
préoccupation la nature de la délégation
du pouvoir d'autorisation du Premier
ministre à certains de ses
collaborateurs vous avez fait dans votre
intervention une avancée je pense que
c'est utile et nous allons travailler de
manière positive sur ce sujet mais
spontanément l'idée d'avoir six
personnes à Matignon plus un certain
nombre d'autres qui dans les différents
cabinets peuvent intervenir à la place
de l'autorité politique tout ceci nous
paraît pouvoir être dangereux si les
personnalités ne sont pas en
responsabilité avec des délégations car
au fond qui viennent quand quand on est
membre du cabinet du premier ministre on
a naturellement des responsabilités si
on pouvait être désigné et pour le
moment dans le texte il n'y avait pas de
précision de cette délégation moi très
franchement je vais vous dire le fond de
ma conviction ma conviction c'est qu'on
ne risque pas grandchose avec ce texte
avec les pouvoirs publics les systèmes
de contrôle les systèmes sont de mon
point de vue pour les pouvoirs publics
responsables ce que je crains le plus
c'est comptenu de l'accès à ces
technologies qui coûte pas cher c'est
que des agents en privé viennent se
servir de toutes ces techniques et
organisent dans notre société avec des
officines des dispositifs qui à
l'extérieur de eux sans contrôle eux
sans aucune éthique puissent venir dans
notre société chercher à dabiliser telle
entreprise telle organisation tel parti
politique ou tel autre c'est ça qui me
préoccupe d'une certain le plus donc je
ne souhaite pas qu'il y ait un certain
nombre de gens qui puissent trouver une
filière en ayant eu des nominations un
moment ou un autre qui leur donne accès
à un certain nombre de responsabilités
et qu'on retrouve 2 ans après en train
de proposer leur servicees à telle ou
telle organisation ou à telle ou telle
structure je pense que ce qui est moi je
crois à l'éthique de l'État je crois aux
responsabilités si les gens sont
délégués et dans un système responsable
je ne crains pas si les choses étaient
moins précises et si les dégations
étaient plus confleus je serais très
inquiet j'ai noté monsieur le Premier
ministre dans votre discours une
orientation qui peut nous permettre
d'avoir un accord 3ème sujet c'est la
préoccupation que on peut avoir sur la
protection du secret de la défense
nationale ce secret défense je vois
qu'on pourrait y avoir accès de manière
escalité alors je comprends bien le côté
subversif de cette réflexion et de
pouvoir penser qu'un certain nombre de
Haute
Autorité juridiquement compétente puisse
avoir
excalité le l'habilitation mais
l'habilitation c'est une procédure de
droit commun et idé Roger doit rester
assez exceptionnel si le secret défense
si on veut le protéger et quand on le
protège on protège l'information mais on
protège aussi la personne qui est
détenteur de ce de ce message ou de ces
informations et donc les dépositaire
comme le message et les institutions
peuvent se trouver protégées avoir
accès au statut d'habilitation de secret
dééfense sans que on ait eu les
procédures d'habilitation ça pose un
petit problème je ne ferai pas de ce
sujet un sujet de rupture majeure mais
je veux attirer l'attention des uns des
autres et je demande la compréhension de
monsieur le ministre de la Défense sur
le fait que le secret défense c'est pas
quelque chose de banal c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on acquierre comme ça
simplement par un statut c'est quelque
chose qui est lié à des fonctions et qui
engage la responsab ilité et s'il y a un
statut de droit commun il faut veiller à
ce que statut puisse avoir le minimum de
dérogation possible enfin je voudrais
vous dire que ce qui nous paraît aussi
très important c'est que l'efficacité de
cette réforme dépendra beaucoup des
moyens budgétaires et financiers alloués
à l'ensemble de ce dispositif d'un côté
des moyens budgétaires et de l'autre
côté des procédures qu'on devra essayer
de rendre le moins bureaucratique
possible nous comprenons bien et nous
approuvons les procédures qui sont
proposées mais nous voyons de l'autre
côté que tout ça va conduire à une
organisation administrative et
bureaucratique immense et donc il va
falloir faire attention à la fois à
l'utilisation des moyens et à
l'efficacité des procédures c'est un
point je crois très important c'est vrai
de la CNCR que ces moyens humains et
budgétaires vont nous exiger euh un
certain nombre d'efforts de même que le
GIC qui va se trouver lui aussi avec des
besoins considérable il convient d'être
conscient de tout cela mais Monsieur le
Premier Ministre mesdames messieurs les
ministres sous ces réserves avec les
observations qui auront lieu dans le
cadre de ces débats la commission des
affaires étrangères de la défense et des
forces armées donne un avis favorable à
l'adoption du projet de loi relatif au
renseignement et dit vra un moment où
dans ce pays tout le monde se sent
républicain c'est le moment de donner à
notre République les moyens de sa
conservation
merci merci monsieur le
président